welcome to the program we begin in
Moscow where for the second time in a
matter of days a drone Strikers hit a
high-rise Tower in the city's Financial
District Russia blames Ukraine for the
attacks the 50-story skyscraper houses
three Ministries and was first targeted
on Sunday now defense officials say
three other drones were downed in the
capital and surrounding areas on Tuesday
Ukraine has not acknowledged the attacks
we are going to see the tower where the
explosion happened the day before
yesterday and people showed us and we
were walking there and then suddenly
there was this explosion and we
immediately ran there were shots of
glass and then smoke Rising then the
security services started running that
way the shots were really big of more or
less that's crossed over to Yulia Chapo
valva in Moscow and president zielinski
has said that the war is coming to
Russia and now the same location hit
twice by a drone strike in Moscow I mean
what are authorities saying about this
was the first official who gave some
details about the incident according to
him no casualties were reported but he
said that one of the drones flew into
the very same Tower in Moscow city which
had been hit last time two days ago the
facade on the 21st floor was damaged as
a result with 150 square meters of
glazing broken and then the ministry of
Defense blamed kiev for that tax they
spoke about three drones launched on
facilities in Moscow and the Moscow
region two of them were destroyed by air
defense systems in Moscow suburbs in the
west and the third one was jammed by
electronic warfare so it seems it
crashed in into one of the towers so the
building is a government complex and the
IQ quarter it is housing several
branches of three Russian Ministries and
we understand should the attack have
taken place in the daytime it would have
been hard to avoid the casualties and by
the way the first attacks um after the
first attacks on Sunday the management
of Yandex that's Russia's largest search
engine they canceled all night shifts
for their employees who work in Moscow
City uh so two days ago on Sunday July
the 30s when the first drones flew into
the buildings in Moscow City many were
saying that there was not proper
reaction from the authorities uh
Vladimir Putin was at the Navy parade as
it was Navy day in Russia who was
hosting his African counterparts there
and basically he said nothing about the
the Santa attacks and his press
secretary Dimitri peskov later called
them acts of desperation by Ukraine as
the country is unsuccessful on the
battlefield so we're waiting for more
official reaction hours many questions
remain unanswered as from where exactly
the drones were launched how that could
it could be possible to jam the drones
the way then they hit one of this one of
the same building when all when all this
is going to end and so on and so forth
thank you in Moscow for us